this has been one of the biggest news
weeks in a very long time I don't really
remember the last time we had a news
week as big as this week rife with
guilty verdicts and guilty pleas and
lies and lies on top of lies from the
administration and we now have a new
interview that Donald Trump did with Fox
& Friends it aired in full this morning
although there were some snippets of it
that were released yesterday and
according to Donald Trump's own words
during this Fox News interview he admits
that he did know about the hush money
payments that his now convicted lawyer
Michael Cohen made to mistresses in
order for them not to talk about their
escapades with Donald Trump Trump claims
he knew about it after the fact which of
course is in direct contradiction with
the tape on which it appears that
Michael Cohen is discussing the payments
with Trump but nonetheless we now know
that Michael Cohen is pleading guilty to
crimes for those payments which means
that Donald Trump now is connected to
something that is criminal now you are
going to hear in this clip I'm going to
play for you you are going to hear Trump
deny that the payments had anything to
do with campaign funds but legally
speaking the payments broke the law
which is why Michael Cohen pleaded
guilty but in this clip Donald Trump
appears to admit to a federal crime
which crime that is actually depends on
whether you think he's telling the truth
or not either way there's a federal
crime in here take a listen to this and
then we'll discuss it later on
I knew later on but you have to
understand Anthony what he did and they
weren't taken out of campaign finance
that's a big thing that's a much bigger
thing did they come out of the campaign
they didn't come out of the campaign
they came from me and I tweeted about it
you know I put I don't know if you know
but I tweeted about the payments but
they didn't come out of campaign in fact
my first question when I heard about it
was did they come out of the campaign
because that could be a little dicey and
they didn't come out of the campaign
that's big but they worry that's not a
it's not even a campaign violation if
you look at President Obama he had a
massive campaign violation but he had a
different Attorney General and they
viewed it a lot different you have to
mention Obama right I mean why not at
this point please get this guy in a room
with Robert Muller or mole those
investigators and put them under oath
because that explanation might work on
Fox News's anally Earhart but there is
no way in hell that that explanation
works on a seasoned federal investigator
and aside from the de la gala T which
we'll get to isn't it stunning how
casually Trump discusses hush money
payoffs to multiple mistresses totally
matter-of-factly as if the only relevant
part is did the hush money payoffs to
your multiple mistresses come from your
campaign funds or did they come from
your personal funds now we have heard
from a lawyer former ethics lawyer for
Barack Obama norm Eisen who says that
Donald Trump seems to inadvertently
admit to a federal crime now you might
say well hold on a second David Trump
says he knew about the payment after
they happened not before even if it's a
lie that's not an admission of a crime
that's true but there's another crime
that Trump appears to have admitted to
here Trump signed his federal
disclosures in 2017 for 2016 and didn't
include that debt to Michael Cohen for
the payoffs okay legally Trump is
supposed to list that debt the repayment
of that money to Michael Cohen if it did
if indeed it didn't come from campaign
funds on his financial disclosure he
didn't do it
Trump says in the interview he knew
about the payments and he made the
payments himself that doesn't show up on
paper anywhere was this one of these
infamous elusive perjury traps set up by
Ainsley Earhardt I don't think so I
think Trump doesn't know what he's
talking about maybe Ainsley Earnhardt
let him talk for too long you have to
walk him through the line of reasoning
and the questioning otherwise he's going
to admit to some really bad things
Citizens for responsibility and ethics
in Washington has already made a
criminal referral against Donald Trump
has led to Citizens for responsibility
and ethics to demand that a complaint be
made and now the full story is that
there has been lie after lie after lie
from Trump on this so it actually could
be way worse than Trump even appears to
be admitting here
according to Michael Cohen Trump
directed him to make the payments in
advance now if that's true it's way
worse than what Trump appears to be
admitting to here on the Fox News
interview you'll remember that Trump
first said he didn't know about any of
this stuff at all even recently he made
that claim now he says he did know about
the payments but only after and that
campaign funds weren't used the truth
could be anything and there's no reason
to think that we're all tamanna get the
truth from Trump I think it's gonna take
more work to get the truth also Trump
not shockingly doesn't understand
campaign finance law he says Cohen
pleaded guilty to something that's not a
crime
can you imagine you get in a room a
judge prosecutors a defendant who's a
lawyer in Michael Cohen Cohen's lawyers
everybody in the room is familiar with
the law and somehow you end up having a
guilty plea to things that aren't crimes
how exactly does that happen you must
have a room full of moronic people who
are accepting guilty pleas for things
that aren't crimes but here is the most
important part whether or not the money
came from Trump's campaign funds it's a
crime either way if the money came from
campaign funds it's an illegal use of
campaign funds if the money for stormy
Daniels and Karen McDougal did not come
from campaign funds it's a contribution
for the purposes of influencing the
campaign above the legal donation limit
either way you're talking about a crime
here yeah Trump must be ecstatic now
that he was elected president because if
he was just a commoner if he had lost
the election he probably would have been
indicted by now because he seems just as
guilty as Michael Cohen is I disagree I
think if he had lost the election people
wouldn't even have paid attention to
this because he wouldn't have been
president and a lot of this stuff only
came to light because of Trump's
unhinged tweeting once he was
actually elected and people started
asking questions so I think you're right
he would have been more legally exposed
but it would have been less likely that
any of this would have been looked at
with such scrutiny wasn't Hillary the
one who was supposed to end up in prison
yeah that didn't happen did it maybe she
still will I don't know eventually they
will fully shift to the idea of the law
as this kind of vague arbitrary societal
construction which it is at its base
right like that's what crime is it is
arbitrary society decides what are we
going to make a crime and what are we
not going to make a crime but it is a
crime right that's the important thing
it is a crime in 2018 and the only
question now that that remains is can it
be proven that Trump directed Cohen to
make these payments and that's what we
hopefully will learn about soon